Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us!
Have you enjoyed the past two days... ...of Advent debuts.
It's been a busy two days for hololive English -Advent- members like us, and Biboo, and Shiori, and Nerissa, but...
Did you enjoy them?
Did you watch them?
Did you enjoy the two days of Advent debuts?
How was it?
How's it been?
We hope you enjoyed them!
Did you find a new oshi, maybe?
It's always good to get new favorites.
Well... Today is a very special day because this is the pilot episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Does it seem kind of mysterious?
Is it mysterious?
Well, maybe a happy mysterious, but... Yes, FUWAMOCO Morning is not that mysterious.
It's our special live program held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Surprise!
It's a short format morning show.
I guess it might be a late night show.
Which one is it for you?
What time is it?
Is it a morning show?
Is it a late night show?
Or is it a... Should we change the name?
Yeah, which one?
Morning?
Afternoon?
Late night, late night.
FUWAMOCO Morning in your heart.
But if it's like "FUWAMOCO Night Time", that's a different kind of show, no?
FUWAMOCO in your heart.
Morning in your heart, but also FUWAMOCO in your heart.
FUWAMOCO Morning, what we aim to do is we aim to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
You might have noticed with our schedule, but we're really hoping to start our day together with you.
And together.
You know, playing fun games and doing other different things.
And that way we can all have a really happy, healthy life routine all together.
Yeah, it's important.
We need you Ruffians in good shape, okay?
You gotta stay tip-top healthy.
You have to be the hot dog of every day.
Right?
Is that okay?
You're good with being healthy, right?
Well, maybe it might happen whether you like it or not.
Anyways, we'd be really honored if you could spend time with us like this.
And Japanese too!
Before we forget!
FUWAMOCO Morning is...
FUWAMOCO Morning is a regular morning variety show.
I know it's a bit late for everyone in Japan, but our goal is to help you start your day off on the right paw.
That's the goal.
That's the goal!
Healthy!
But yeah, today's just the pilot episode, but we really hope that FUWAMOCO Morning can be a really warm, cozy show that we can all enjoy together.
Maybe as you roll out of bed, or maybe on your way to work, or you're like, ahh, today's no good, damida.
Then maybe we can put on FUWAMOCO Morning and be like, okay, I'll get out of bed.
That would make us really happy.
But yeah, since today's the pilot episode,
It's a bit different.
It's episode 0, right?
Right?
Episode 0.
Pilot episodes never really end up to be, like, the actual show, right?
Well, we'll all have to find out!
Yeah, right!
It's gonna be a journey.
What does FUWAMOCO Morning become?
Right?
It's still a mystery to us, too.
Yeah.
But... I think it's good like that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But, first and foremost, we have one thing.
We wanted to say...
Big, big thank you!
De-den!
We've reached 300,000 ruffians!
Can you believe it?
It's all thanks to everyone!
Thank you!
I don't really, like, understand.
We're absolutely blown away.
It's actually kind of dizzying for me.
Arigatou gozaimasu!
Thank you so much for all your support!
And of course we're really thankful to our senpai's hard work building up hololive to make it the amazing place that it is today.
Even though today is... Does it still count?
It's our first day as brand new members of hololive English.
We would really like to do the same, you know, to make hololive an even more amazing and even more warm place for our future kouhai, too.
Isn't it a bit early to be thinking that?
It's a little bit early, but... It's important, you know?
It's important, so... It'd make us really happy if you continue to let everyone know about all of us at Alvin, and if you could continue to spread your love of hololive everywhere you go.
Maybe even FUWAMOCO could be included in that too, huh?
Is that okay?
Thank you for all the good ones!
You know what?
I saw on Twitter some Ruffians already have a wishy-washy mark.
Yeah, I saw it too!
I saw it too!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
We're very happy puppies right now.
Once Twitter starts to be nice to us again, we'll be able to look at more stuff.
So it's been a bit difficult for us, but we want to see lots of stuff.
I noticed
I made a spelling, a silly typo, and actually a couple tweets.
And I wanted to retweet it, but then I got embarrassed.
I haven't really been able to look at the tweet.
Did you notice it?
You didn't notice, right?
Please don't notice.
Please don't notice, okay?
You know, I even asked Fuwawa to copy what she was gonna post, but Moco-chan looked at it and she said it's okay.
I was sleepy.
You didn't notice, okay.
I'll do better.
But you know, deleting tweets, that's no good.
You can't delete it.
Even if you have a typo.
To us, what?
We're gonna make another big mistake and then delete our tweets today.
Just because we said it.
Twitter, be nice to us.
My fingers... Which typo?
No, don't look, okay?
Don't look, don't look, don't look.
Now they're gonna be watching our tweets and be like... We just... No more typos, okay, Mococo-chan?
We did it to ourselves.
Well, the next thing... You might have noticed we had a bit of a surprise for you.
De-den!
Kaibutsu!
Did you hear?
Did you watch it?
Our first cover song.
You didn't miss it, right?
It was released at the very end.
We kind of forgot!
Yeah.
Kaibutsu by Yoasobi-san.
Yeah, we covered Kaibutsu by Yoasobi-san.
Moco-chan just said that.
But, it's... It's... Really happy.
What did you think of it?
It's really good!
You like it?
Thank you!
Cover is fire!
It's...
It made us really happy because, you know, it's our first cover song with FUWAMOCO.
And, you know, we actually, we don't really have that much experience recording.
No.
We just like to howl.
We just howl.
And that's it.
Yeah.
You don't record the howling, you just howl, right?
You just howl and then you're done.
So, it's really special to us to have a recording that not only we can listen, but you can listen to too.
And, you know, Kaibutsu.
We chose it for a very special reason.
Moco-chan, do you want to talk about it more?
Well, I feel like recently I've had lots of just like, lightning.
Hirameki.
Hirameki, like, it just strikes me.
That's what kaibutsu was.
It was like, yoshi yaro!
I'm gonna do it!
Kaibutsu!
At first I was like...
But after reading the lyrics, it really really really resonated with us, you know?
The meaning of the lyrics for songs is always really important to us.
So we'd like you to check them out if you can.
The reason why we covered Kaibutsu this time was because the lyrics really resonated with our hearts.
That's right.
That's the reason.
Yarimashita.
Utawasete itadakimashita.
Atarashii challenge deshita.
It was a new challenge according to- Yeah, there's so many harmonies.
Right?
Usually when we howl together it's just like, BAU BAU!
And maybe like a little bit, BAU BAU!
Moco-chan you'll do the BAU BAU.
Right?
That's accurate.
We're a bit nervous, but...
Hamahiro-san did such a good job with the mix magic.
And Hae-san with the illustration.
Ohmika-san, beautiful video!
You checked it out, right?
Did you notice all the little things?
All the cool things?
Go find them.
If you watched it once, maybe it's time to go watch it twice after FUWAMOCO Morning.
Right?
But it was a really, really fun experience.
We're looking forward to hopefully doing more.
Yeah.
We know we talked about the lyrics being really important to us, but maybe if you don't understand Japanese, it might be difficult to understand the meaning, and that's why we did an English translation ourselves!
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO did the English translation.
It's not quite ready yet, though.
Not quite yet.
So we're hoping that it'll be up soon, but we'll let you know, okay?
Please look forward to it!
But still watch it now, and then you can watch it once they're done, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can turn off all the lights,
Make it fullscreen and watch it like you're in a movie theater.
Really loud, right?
Make the neighbors angry.
That's the recommendation.
Please watch it, okay?
As for one thing... I thought maybe we should address... It's still our first day, but... This.
There's a misunderstanding!
BAU BAU BAU!
This.
I was framed!
I was framed.
During the collab.
Both Calli-senpai and A-chan thought that Fuwawa said something that was wrong.
No!
I didn't say anything bad!
I'm not the first avid member to say a bad word!
No, no, no, no.
Ruffians, you're not thinking that I really said that, right?
You know I'm not that kind of person, right?
We are.
Us and Biboo are not that type of person.
I don't know about Nurse and Shiori, but... Not us and Biboo.
You know, it happened when I was explaining, you know, how...
We got into the cell and everything.
And I said, we got locked up!
But they thought it was fluffed up.
Moco-chan, you're gonna say it straight like that?
But a bit different than that.
A bit different than that!
I think A-chan and Calli-senpai, maybe they need to get their ears adjusted.
Their minds out of the clutter.
Ruffians, you too!
You too if you thought that.
You have to believe us, okay?
I believe them, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for believing.
You understand that?
I am not the first member of A.V.I.N.
to say anything.
And I will never be the last member to say anything.
I will never be a member that says something bad like that.
Got it?
Understood?
I'm not too sure.
Now that we all understand that... We wanted to talk about the debut goods!
The debut goods!
Have you checked them out?
Of course FUWAMOCO would want to talk about the debut goods, right?
Somebody probably told them.
Not that.
We're really excited.
Do you understand how amazing this is?
Do you understand?
You already bought them!
Thank you!
Well, the reason why we wanted to talk about them is... You know, FUWAMOCO, this is really big.
This is really exciting!
I think for a lot of people, they sort of think that goods are given and it's just gonna happen, right?
But it's not!
No, it's not!
We're really, really excited.
We hope you are too.
We hope you check them out, you know.
There's the acrylic stands, the acrylic panels.
There's acrylic laminates.
I am really excited about those.
There's the stained glass.
The strap!
The stained glass strap!
And of course the voices.
The voice too.
Yes, the pre-escape voices.
Really, really fun to be able to record it.
Ah, I forgot my Japanese.
Did you guys check out our Advent merch?
Our debut merch is on sale!
It's on sale!
I can't stop getting excited.
The reason I wanted to talk about our merch today is because I think it's really important to us.
Wow!
Wow deshioi!
Please check it out.
Yeah, we didn't know.
We haven't decided how many goods, how many merch sets we're supposed to buy.
Yeah, because you're supposed to buy three.
Three!
That's the otaku rule, right?
I can't remember, I just remember three.
One to, like, love?
One for saving.
And what was the other one?
To love again when the other one gets loved up?
Maybe.
But it's okay, you can buy more than three too.
An army.
An army of FUWAMOCO!
That is fun though.
I do have a little army too.
It's good to have collections that make you happy, you know?
Being surrounded by the ones you love most.
I hope you check it out, especially the pre-escape voice.
That was really... I wasn't sure if I was doing things right.
It was fun, but it was a bit scary.
Yeah.
We're not gonna spoil anything, so you'll have to give it a listen.
But let us know what you thought of it, okay?
I'm sure your heart will be beating just as fast as ours were, so... You got it!
Thank you!
Please listen!
Well, we also, it wasn't just the pre-escape voice that we recorded, but we also did the starting voice!
You might have seen them because all the other hololive members have been releasing them, but it's kind of nice because with the start of Advent, it's also the start of our starting voices.
We all, all of the other members recorded in both English and Japanese.
Both of them.
And I know, for us, like... Not June.
July.
It's June.
It's June, June, June, July!
July, July!
It's July.
But you know, for Shiori, and for Bijou, and for Nerissa, it wasn't...
It wasn't a walk in the park.
No, it wasn't a walk in the park for them to record it in Japanese.
So, you know, we all helped out each other.
And we had a little bit of a listen.
And it's really, really cute.
We recommend it a lot.
Please check them out as well, okay?
There's a lot of different variations.
Cute morning voices, sleepy voices, grumpy voices.
Especially Moco-chan's grumpy voice.
But you never know what it's going to quite be like, so... I can't wait to listen.
Maybe like a week or so.
Please listen to the starting voice.
It's both in English and Japanese.
All the Advent members did it, so please check it out.
This is very important information for FUWAMOCO Morning.
We wanted to let you know that starting next time, there will be a new corner for FUWAMOCO Morning!
We'd like to introduce two new segments called Doggie of the Day.
We'll start with the first one.
The next FUWAMOCO Morning will have a new corner.
The first one is called Doggie of the Day.
There's a corner called Doggie of the Day, and we're hoping that you'll send us your best Puppers for us to introduce and brighten everyone's day.
We've already seen some very bestest friends.
They're so cute.
They've been being sent in to help FUWAMOCO, and it's been very, very helpful.
We're very happy to see it, but we'd also like to nominate them with the FUWAMOCO Morning, the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Hashtag.
Oh, you know, we can introduce them.
On that topic.
You tweeted.
Hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
Maybe they have you.
Ruffians.
Have you.
It's okay if you don't know what to tweet, you know.
There's always BAU BAU.
So...
Go and tweet.
BAU BAU!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Or a good popper.
Oh, good popper.
Yeah, you know.
But yes, we'll be waiting to see your furry and fuzzy dog friends.
And fluffy.
Furry and fluffy.
Yeah.
Ah, I forgot about fluffy.
But not just that, we also have the Today I Went for a Walk set.
Yeah!
Now, um...
It's not just today's doggy segment.
It's like today's walk.
It's not today's walk.
Today we went for a walk.
Ah, we're doing it right.
We're doing it right.
Yeah, there's a segment like that.
Yes, so for today I went for a walk.
We'd like to ask you to maybe submit a picture.
If you want.
Yeah, if you want.
And a small report when you go out for a walk using the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Yeah, FUWAMOCO Morning.
You know how much we like to go for walks, right?
Walks are so good.
So we thought that it would make us really happy if we could hear about all the wonderful little adventures that you'd be going on.
Yeah.
Usually we like to take little photos and stuff like that to remember like, oh this happened today and stuff.
Right!
So we thought that it would make you happy too if you did that.
You know, like, today's flowers are really pretty!
Right!
Or you saw something like, haha that's silly!
Those kind of things.
But only if you're comfortable.
Yeah.
Yeah, you could, like, share a photo.
Yeah, flowers, nature.
Those kind of things.
Anything that made you smile.
Yeah.
If it made you smile, then it'll definitely make us smile.
Right!
So please make sure you add the hashtag FUWAMOCOMORNING to your tweet.
And if you could include a sentence or two just about how your walk was, maybe how it made you feel.
Even if it's like a rainy day.
Yeah, you know, just what made today's walk extra special.
Right.
Yeah.
We'll be looking forward to your stories of getting outside, stretching the puppies, getting some fresh air.
Those kind of things.
Can you do that?
We'll be waiting, okay?
We'll be waiting, so make sure you do it.
De-den.
Den.
We also need more help.
We need more help.
We're a little bit needy sometimes.
Hopefully that's okay, but...
Yes!
On tomorrow!
On tomorrow at 6pm PT, 9pm ET, 1am GMT, and 10am JST.
We have our first Q&A stream!
We're gonna be doing it!
Tomorrow!
Yes, tomorrow!
So we'd like you to ask, we've seen a lot of questions, a lot of really good questions so far.
But I'm sure you probably have still lots of questions.
So if you have any, please send them to us with the hashtag, helpfuwamoco.
And we'll pick out as many as we can, okay?
It's right there on the screen.
Yeah, tomorrow, tomorrow!
Is it that shocking?
Well, you can think of a question before tomorrow, right?
Yeah, there's a lot, a lot of questions I think you could think of.
You know, like, what's it like being twin demon dog sisters?
What's life like together?
What's Pero like?
You know, those kind of things, right?
So, we're gonna be looking forward to your questions, okay?
But is tomorrow a thing?
I don't get it.
I'm happy, you're happy about it.
I see lots of good questions.
There's a lot of good questions.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, helpfuwamoco.
That's cute in Japanese.
Helpfuwamoco.
Helpfuwamoco, yeah!
Help me!
We need a lot of help.
But maybe it's a bit more fun now, right?
But that's not all!
After FUWAMOCO Morning today, later in the evening we have VLOG!
Tonight!
Even better than tomorrow.
Tonight at 6PM PT, 9PM ET, 1AM GMT, and 10AM JST.
We'll be playing our first game, Fogs.
We've become a cutie hot dog fog.
We've never played it before, but it looks very cute and colorful, and we make cute noises.
Yeah, it's tonight!
Even closer.
We're really looking forward to it.
I feel like it's been such a long time since I played a game together with you, Moco-chan.
It'll be very relaxing.
I think.
Really?
We're not gonna, like, fight or argue?
I wanna go this way!
I wanna go that way!
If we wanna go one way later, we can just do that later.
Yeah.
It's not that hard.
You'll have to come and check it out to see how things go, okay?
Yeah.
I think this is maybe the only cute game on our schedule this week.
All of them are sort of scary or tough.
Yeah, but... It'll be okay because you'll be there with us, right, Ruffians?
Right!
You'll join us, right?
Right?
Right!
Well... Before...
Before we get going, we'd like to share our schedule and just have another little peek.
One last time.
It's a bit tiny, but if you'd like to see it a bit bigger, you can check out our Twitter as well.
We have some very exciting things coming up and we'd really like you to make sure that you come and walk out at our FUWAMOCO Walk and War Party!
On Saturday?
Saturday?
Yeah.
On Sunday, we'll be doing our first ever karaoke stream.
We'll be singing a song called Walkin' for a Party.
It's kind of like Rock n' Rawr.
It's got an interesting name.
We're really excited.
There's a lot of good music, a lot of songs.
Good songs are good!
Especially anime songs too.
We hope you'll be there!
We also have a very, very mysterious
Twice stream on Sunday.
So it's a question, question, question.
What could it be?
We don't know.
Question, question, question.
And also we have Advent Club playing.
Yes!
Left 4 Dead 2.
We need your strength, so please.
Please.
Please, please.
But I'm really looking forward to it though.
Because even though it's kind of scary, you know, Shiori and Bijou and Ursa will be there, so it'll be okay, right?
Right.
Well, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd actually like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today.
Is that okay?
Okay!
Say BAU BAU now!
BAU BAU!
RUN!
Alex!
BAU BAU!
It's so fast I can't read it!
Nisha!
BAU BAU!
Ryo-san!
Claw!
BAU BAU!
Mine!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!